Republicans are now trying to take
credit for the infrastructure bill that
they voted against including Senator
Tommy tuberville tuberville
um tweeting about how it's a good thing
despite the fact that he voted against
it this is an absolute and total classic
from Republicans they virtue signal
about how their fiscal conservatives and
we can't afford it and how are we going
to pay for it and that and deficit
and then it does some things for their
state it does some things for their
constituents it creates some jobs in the
area that they represent and all of a
sudden they say hey I was in I was in
the Senate when that was uh when we we
did that yeah but we did it despite you
not thanks to your help these folks are
pathetic I don't know if they know it
but we know it